for us we gotta start with some sex in
the city of course
because it's the best show ever and i
still binge it all the time and we're
all patiently waiting for the reboot to
come and save us
all and distract us out of our woes and
we know carrie miranda and charlotte are
back but what about the rest of the cast
i can't stop thinking about this well
willie garson is back who plays stanford
by the way i've known willie like my
entire life it's hilarious i love him
there's rumors that miranda steve and mr
big
won't be returning wait what yeah will
not that's the rumor that they won't be
returning and i'm
furious what is what he wants
you didn't need this today right well i
want i i
[ __ ] you take it away rossi i do i'm set
to talk
i know we'll listen we've all are still
processing the kim cattrall
news that she's not going to be there
right samantha uh but now us weekly says
actor chris noth who played big he's
finally commented on this saying
very cryptically quote everything
changes including announcements in the
rags which means
the magazine so maybe it's a fluid
situation girl we need you now
all right i need them all to show up
enough of this playing coy will they i
want that you're showing up mr big you
understand
steve i know
after the year we've had we need this uh
we need you to come together for us
all right team just take one for the
team we're going to do this
okay it's design week and we've got an
amazing
story about how technology is changing
the way
we design our kitchens apartment therapy
reports a company called bluestar can
custom print a decal for you
for your fridge and oven to make it
perfectly match with your wallpaper
or just turn it into art itself you need
to have and this is an important detail
a high res picture so that they can scan
it correctly
and properly and then you can turn
anything into anything i
loved this story maybe we can decal the
entire cast of sex in the city together
now you're thinking i mean the
possibilities are endless would you ever
do something like this
in your kitchen absolutely would you
match your wallpaper or something
offsetting well i love like when wood
goes over a fridge
or a fridge has a color or i love when
kids pictures are magnetized to the
fridge which now all fridges
metal doesn't magnetize anymore so
thanks so much for that development
um it devastates me and then you scotch
tape the art but then that becomes like
it pulls off just let me put some
magnets in kids art
but yes i would love to turn any
appliances into something more artistic
we did a drew's news version we do oh
yeah yes right rossi
yes so is that going in your kitchen
well i was thinking we could cook it
here and be like a facebook or something
like you have cool industrial gen z or
office style all right when you do i
want to see it whatever you put in your
kitchen okay but we'll do it together
okay
what's our next story uh well finally
drew we've got a lovely story about
prince harry and meghan markle
everybody's talking about them right now
huff post reports
the couple has stepped in to help the
genesis women's shelter in dallas texas
after everything's gone so
wrong in dallas it was badly damaged in
the storm megan and harry
they recently quit their royal post but
this proves they're planning to keep up
their public service which is such a
large part of being a royal
and they actually sit down are you going
to watch with oprah for an in-depth
yeah march 7th the same day
actually as the queen's commonwealth day
message from windsor castle so they're
like almost counter programming each
other which is interesting
i'm very impressed with everything that
they're doing
and actually um megan and harry's
inspiring story
of service actually led us to this story
and we're moving on to another pair of
do-gooders
or drew gooders doing amazing work
for their home state the guest family
barbecue in waco texas
survived the storm and now they are
firing up their pits to feed
encore linemen who are working
tirelessly
to restore the power in their community
and guess what they're here to tell us
about it the owners of guest family
barbecue
jean vinnie cove and reed guests hi
guys thank you for doing this
oh gene and reed thank you so much for
doing what you're doing
you survived the storm what was
the uh connection for you of what to do
next
by feeding the workers who are
tirelessly getting the power back on
yeah reid actually called me on monday
morning
and uh he actually wanted to open up a
shelter for anybody who
lost power or waters or a lot of our
friends and family
and did colleagues and after talking it
through a little bit and figuring out
hey i don't know if we can open as a
home as a shelter just we weren't
capable of doing that
uh we got a call from encore and encore
needed one meal
just to feed their staff and i called
reid and reid said absolutely this is
our time
and um we kind of made a decision that
we're going to feed the
all the people that we can and we
started um on monday afternoon
firing up our pits and getting going to
feed the people of encore
yeah it started out as just one meal and
after we looked at our inventory and saw
what we had and what we were able to
give it was
a pretty easy decision to uh try to get
these guys back in here so we
ended up doing three meals a day for
three days
uh for all of them so it was like 700
meals something like that just for me
i mean first of all thank you for
what you are doing ross well i just you
know i'm so inspired because we look at
this stuff on the news and you think
what can we do and here you guys are
doing it you've seen this devastation
first hand too
and i'm curious what your message is uh
for everyone in texas watching right now
texas is as strong of a state as they
come and i think this was a way of
showing that we weren't prepared for
this
in no way shape or form a lot of this
has lost food and water
and a lot of restaurants that we know
we're not able to reopen the same way we
were so we were fortunate
um we were we were able to pass it on
but we want to continue this and we are
going to continue this
and we hope that texas continues to do
that and continues to help our neighbors
is this a seat of an idea that
businesses in their communities should
reach out to other businesses and see
what can come together
for sure everything that we've been able
to do for other people during this
during this time
has come from tons of phone calls and
tons of
uh just you know communication between
non-profits between the city
our uh awesome mayor you know it's
you have to you have to communicate and
people aren't necessarily willing to ask
for help and people don't want to
always ask for help so it's good to call
people and check on them and make sure
that
you know if you have something to offer
when you call it's almost easier for
them to take the help okay we're
bringing this
food you know and a lot of people want
to help
but don't know how when and where so i
think this is a really
great example of how communication
can be a real game changer for people
this is just it's so inspiring on
so many levels and in honor of the great
work that you're doing
for your community our friends at tyson
foods
is donating more than fifteen thousand
dollars worth of protein
products to help continue to feed those
who are working endlessly in fact the
18-wheeler truck
is on its way right now right now
thank you i just want to say a huge
thank you again to our friends at tyson
who
are helping us be a part of moments like
this
and reed and jean for everything that
you are doing there are so many layers
to this story that are inspiring
innovative and incredibly hopeful but
most of all to everyone in texas
we just want you to know that our
thoughts and our prayers
are with you
[Music]
you